good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today his scp-797 tainment
procedures each specimen of scp-797
tainment cell at bio site 66 100 grams
of dry brine shrimp is to be sprinkled
over each object monthly that this is
not available 500 grams of household
dust will suffice the previous sentence
has been stricken from the document it
has been determined that bio-psych 66
maintenance staff removed significantly
more than the necessary quantity of dust
from the d-class dorms monthly this dust
is to be collected in the usual dustpan
bags and delivered as necessary no more
than 500 grams per specimen is necessary
or advised should any throw pillows or
similar objects appear they are to be
placed in separate containment
immediately and the presiding researcher
notified the objects are not to be
removed from containment except as
authorized for testing
description members of scp-797
superficial appearance but always retain
the appearance of a net or wolven item
of bedding made from an unfamiliar but
for a soft natural fiber resembling high
quality merino wool blend but identified
as an individual's mass ranges from
approximately 0.5 to 6 kilograms and
does not change except through ingestion
and excretion so any immediate increase
in area comes at the expense of
thickness and fabric weight the blanket
retains heat unusually well its
coloration and markings are highly
variable it tends strongly towards
pastel hues and patterns resembling
stylized jnanis animals particularly
when it's mass is less than about 2
kilograms the items are living organisms
most similar in physiology and structure
to although alternate hypotheses suggest
fungal origins
full notes may be found in document 799
1a although well insulated they are
apparently cold blooded hence their
adaption for use by intelligent homeo
therms instances of scp-797 requiring
little nutrition what they do need they
draw from organic detritus present in
household dust one specimen is believed
to have survived for years on end in a
damp ill maintained attic living on heat
from the house below and detritus from
the wooden rafters above excretion is
minimal excreta resembled tiny very dry
if forced to survive for long periods
without sufficient nutrition though
scp-797 into a predatory form the
resultant structural changes are
invisible to the casual observer
they consist of modifications to the
digestive tract and feeding orifices the
latter shift from minute dispersed
filter-feeding mouths into a single
large mouth lined
the organism also develops contractile
tissue similar to animal muscle once
this minim or Phasis is complete the SCP
799 individual waits for a large animal
to wrap up in it and become quiescent
sleep is common before opening its mouth
tearing off a few kilograms of biomass
and consuming it the biomass is
apparently reduced to send slurry almost
immediately as even seconds after
feeding there is no visible bulge in the
blanket the mouth is completely
reabsorbed ten minutes after feeding at
this point no evidence of the blankets
nature is available except by x-ray or
by observing this sudden increase in
mass by 40 minutes after feeding the
entire carnivorous digestive system is
reabsorbed and the organism returned to
the filter feeding phase in carnivorous
phase the organism will not feed on
inanimate objects or cold-blooded
animals dr. hypothesizes that its senses
are entirely limited to touch and heat
and then it does not recognize cooler
objects as organic scp-797 case of
carnivorous it takes on a more
quilt-like appearance gradually over the
course of several weeks the quilt
squares along one margin puff up and
slough off to become several small
dollies or throw pillows they offspring
are clones of the individual identical
to it in every way and will grow to a
similar size and reproduce in turn given
suitable conditions the first of the
foundations captive scp-789 population
of individuals at time of writing was
retrieved on from
where it had been residing in the home
of notorious germaphobe
after a metamorphic on his infant
granddaughter a standard biological
sweep revealed the blankets nature and
was taken into containment without
resistance it is not known how many
instances of SCP $7.99 exist outside
foundation containment as they are very
difficult to detect except by genetic
testing extrapolation of growth rates
and reproductive weights from the
specimens in containment suggests that a
filter feeding scp-797 to 60 years and
finally a note from dr. any wild
blankets should be destroyed upon
detection this species is fascinating
but we have a large population in
containment and the wild ones pose too
much risk of public exposure further
research into a possible special
connection with a CP 1626
is ongoing
now okay this concludes our lecture for
today thank you very much for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bashar Muslim Mookie
Jax Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin
Thomas Aldridge Desmond Hoskins Depp's
McGee dr. mortis Johnno Porter Cody
tench Tiber ball on sighs Savin actual
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volume
thank you
[Music]
you